sie sehen an der konstellation der
pressekonferenz ja dass wir uns in einer
besonderen phase befinden einer
geschäftsführung der bundesregierung
einer entstehenden neuen bundesregierung
und das drückt sich auch jetzt hier in
dieser pressekonferenz aus aber wir
haben diese konferenz auch im
bewusstsein abgehalten das system
währungs vollkommen egal ist ob
deutschland sich gerade in einer phase
mit geschäftsführender bundesregierung
befindet oder verhandlungen zur bildung
einer neuen stattfinden und es ihm auch
egal wer sich wie weit schon in seinen
politischen überzeugungen bewegt hat
sondern entscheiden tut nur was diebe
richtigen und wichtigen maßnahmen sind
und deshalb war heute das einzige
kriterium unserer beratung auch dass wir
mitten in der vierten welle uns mit der
aktuellen dramatischen
infektions situation in deutschland
befassen und daraus die möglichst besten
schlussfolgerungen ziehen das betrifft
zum einen die eindämmung des
exponentiellen anstieg und das betrifft
zum anderen das schnelle impfen im
zusammenhang mit der
auffrischungsimpfung zum ersten muss man
sagen dass wir eine wirklich
besorgniserregende situation haben die
es nicht in deutschland gleich verteilt
sondern zwischen den bundesländern gibt
es eine inzidenz spanne von 117 bis
911 aber tatsache ist dass die
bundesweite verdopplung zeit jetzt 13
tage betrug und die verdopplung zeit der
belegung von intensivbetten etwa 23 24
tage und wir wissen damit dass wir uns
eine weitere verdopplung zeit bei der
belegung von intensivbetten nicht
erlauben können das heißt wir brauchen
einen schnellen
stopp oder einbremsen des exponentiellen
anstieg und dem dienen alle beschlüsse
die wir heute gefasst haben natürlich
die in dem auch wenn es darüber
unterschiedliche meinungen gibt das
infektionsschutzgesetz was jetzt heute
im deutschen bundestag und
verabschiedet wurde und morgen im
bundesrat beraten wurde wir wissen und
das ist bedauerlich wir können besser
dastehen wenn die impflücken nicht so
groß wäre und deshalb werden viele
maßnahmen die jetzt ergriffen werden
müssen nicht notwendig gewesen wenn wir
mehr geimpfte menschen hätten und es ist
nie zu spät sich impfen zu lassen auch
jetzt kann man auch mit einer
erstimpfung einen guten beitrag für sich
und für die gemeinschaft leisten
bei den beschlüssen die wir heute
gefasst haben ging es also als erstes um
das impfen hier ist heute die
auffrischungsimpfung auch noch mal von
der ständigen impfkommission gewertet
worden und für alle empfohlen die älter
als 18 sind und zwischen fünf und sechs
monate zurückliegen nach der letzten im
nach der zweiten impfung das ist eine
gute nachricht weil da hat natürlich
auch für alle mehr sicherheit eintritt
aber es ist eine herausfordernde
nachricht weil nunmehr eine große zahl
von menschen
mit einer solchen auffrischungsimpfung
versehen werden muss das sind etwa noch
27 millionen impfungen wenn man überlegt
wie viele menschen bis zum 31 bis zum 30
juni
2021 schon geimpft waren vier millionen
haben wir schon das heißt 27 millionen
bleiben etwa übrig bund und länder
verpflichten sich jedem ein angebot zu
machen und das bedarf einer wirklichen
großen kraftanstrengung die
cds werden gemeinsam als die chefs der
staatskanzleien wenn gemeinsam mit den
gesundheitsministern bis zur regulären
cds konferenz in der nächsten woche
eine planung vornehmen wie das geschehen
kann welche fragestellungen sich auftun
wo unterstützt werden muss thw
katastrophenschutz haben ihre
unterstützung heute auch angeboten und
wir werden dann versuchen hier wirklich
eine große sicherheit hinzubekommen es
wir haben uns befasst mit den
verschiedenen aspekten des lebens jetzt
will ich hier nicht alles da schnitten
auch im infektionsschutzgesetz geregelt
ist 3g am arbeitsplatz die frage der
öffentlichen personennahverkehrs und
anderes aber ich will sagen ein großer
zweck der heutigen
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz bayer wann
muss muss das instrumentarium angewendet
werden dass wir im
infektionsschutzgesetz zur verfügung
haben und da haben wir heute wie ich
finde sehr sehr gute beschlüsse gefasst
wir haben nämlich schwellenwerte
definiert ab denen dann eine bestimmte
flächen deckende im maßnahmenkatalog
eingesetzt werden muss das beginnt bei
einem hospitalisierung synnex sie wissen
dass der für uns jetzt die massgebende
größe ist von 3 denn der überschritten
wird dann muss zweig
flächendeckend eingeführt werden das
heißt also geimpft oder getestet bei den
gesamten veranstaltungen und ähnlich
geimpft und genesen entschuldigung ja
und bei einem schwellenwert von 6 beim
hospitalisierung index wird das ergänzt
durch zweig plus das heißt auch die
geimpften und genesenen müssen getestet
werden und wenn der hospitalisierung
index neue überschreitet da geht es dann
vorbehaltlich der zustimmung der
landtage natürlich weil die dann
sozusagen oder auch notwendig sind nach
der konstruktion des jetzigen
infektionsschutzgesetzes beim
schwellenwert von über 9 beim
hospitalisierung index muss dann das
gesamte instrumentarium der
möglichkeiten eingesetzt werden also
kontakt beschränkungen und verschiedene
einschränkungen
hier ist es ja kein geheimnis bin ich
der meinung dass dieser katalog nicht
ausreicht aber wir haben dann auch eine
vereinbarung getroffen auf die hervis
noch näher eingehen wird das im laufe
der zeit ja die dinge auch wieder
überprüft werden können und es ist sehr
gut dass im infektionsschutzgesetz
enthalten ist eine regelung dass bis zum
15 dezember das ist insbesondere für
sachsen jetzt sehr wichtig maßnahmen die
jetzt noch eingeführt werden auch dann
gelten können es ist wichtig dass bürger
test kostenlos natürlich angeboten
werden und wir haben uns noch einmal
auch bereit erklärt dass wir bei den
pflegekräften im zusammenhang mit der
intensivpflege insbesondere einen bonus
zahlen werden und wir haben heute eine
vereinbarung getroffen die
eine die eine länder bitte ist nämlich
dass das personal in pflegeeinrichtungen
geimpft sein soll das heißt also hier
wird der bund in kürze befinden wir uns
dazu verhalten aber das ist natürlich
eine sehr wichtige mitteilung alles in
allem haben wir damit heute einen ganz
großen maßnahmenkatalog die ich finde
verabredet ich sage allerdings die lage
ist hochdramatisch und es wird jetzt
sehr darauf ankommen dass schnell
gehandelt wird das konsequent gehandelt
wird das besser kontrolliert wird und
dann wird man beobachten müssen ob wir
die dynamik damit stoppen oder zumindest
reduzieren können bei der jetzigen dem
namen laufen wir in eine sehr sehr
schwierige situation rein insbesondere
für alle menschen die in krankenhäusern
und insbesondere in der intensivmedizin
arbeiten die haben immer gesagt wir
wollen unser gesundheitssystem nicht
überfordern wir wissen dass wir das
heute nicht flächendeckend einhalten
können glücklicherweise haben wir noch
an einigen an vielen stellen kapazitäten
aber es ist wirklich
absolute zeit zum handeln und deshalb
war diese mbk heute notwendig und wir
werden permanent beobachten müssen ob
das was wir beschlossen haben reicht
oder ob wir doch zu einer noch
schwierigeren situation kommen was ich
nicht hoffe und es wird jetzt von jedem
auch abhängen sich an die dinge zu
halten ich kann dazu nur auffordern denn
wir sind in einer sehr ernsten situation